all right so I have been waiting with
anxiety to see Twilight start to pop up
everywhere now we have a new trailer for
it which is funny because there was a
trailer that came out before was like a
51 second trailer there was really
nothing to talk about it was a short-ass
trailer the entire thing was just with
the same temperature now so your
daughter is it grass-green yet pms Ines
dawn that was it the entire trailer so I
was like I can't talk about that now we
have like a minute and 10 second long
trailer not much to talk about but
there's enough and this new trailer for
the Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn Part two
starts out Bella's monologuing cuz
apparently she thinks that's what she
does best after 18 years of being
utterly ordinary I finally felt I could
shine we're just funny because alright
18 years of being utterly ordinary she
means human so she gets to go from being
an utterly ordinary human being to being
an utterly ordinary vampire because she
will be utterly ordinary as far as
vampires go so her hating the fact that
she's utterly ordinary she really hates
the fact that she's her I finally felt I
could shine no you're not gonna shine
you're gonna sparkle in the Sun that's
true but you're still gonna be a
boring-ass vampire and you're not gonna
shine for [ __ ] so the plot in this movie
is the Illuminati vampires hate the fact
that Bella and Edward had a kid because
they're like odds an immortal child I
guess that's a bad thing
even though Dakota Fanning looks like a
child hypocrite fellas oh like oh she
was born not bitten she grows every day
she's not an immortal child so does the
Intel just suck or do they like to just
kill kids you got I think they probably
have resources who dropped the ball on
this one I just want to know Tori
they're coming for us so they're all
coming to kill her and the big thing is
the vampires and the werewolves need to
team up again we're join you
we will stand with you a lot of red eyes
around here wait didn't that happen in
the Twilight Saga Eclipse so that this
is really not a new thing that guys have
come before and the vampires and the
werewolves have had to team up before no
big deal but no the Volturi are coming
for them and now that I'll have to fight
that's the point and you have a bunch of
action sequences that doesn't mean [ __ ]
because it's probably just going to be
dialogues or just cutting things
together that look like action sequences
to really intense music for a trailer
they've done that with every single
Twilight movie so they're doing it in
this one I promise
and then they do wait wait what is that
person waterbending right you're not
winning any hearts I get the fact that
you don't want people to think about
this being a Twilight movie but don't
make people think about that one M night
Shyamalan movie that everyone hated oh
my god no disrespect to fans of the
series I'm talking
the movie this being a movie and all I
love taglines and trailers because it
shows the delusions of grandeur
immediately the epic finale that will
live forever I really doubt that I'm
pretty sure to live for as long as it's
in theaters then it will be gone forever
no one will give a [ __ ]
who's even Twilight fans alike yeah the
movies aren't that great but I watch
every one of them doesn't smart like
that but in this entire trailer I can't
help but think about it and you know
what I'm talking about I know it's not
the fact that Michael Sheen looks like
the little drummer boy from your
grandma's cuckoo clock no yeah it's the
Jacob in the little kid pedophile thing
did you guys see the last movie holy
[ __ ]
he's like creepy eye staring at this
little baby oh yeah we don't want to be
too creepy in this movie so we'll bump
her up to the ripe age of seven anybody
are you now that being said show me on
this doll for Jacob touch too creepy
[ __ ] the entire time I'm gonna be like
Chris Hanson should probably bust down
the door and haul those dick head away
and by that I mean I hope because that
would be awesome
coming back to it though why does
Michael Sheen the most accomplished
actor in this entire saga look like
Liberace's gay bellhop why is he dressed
like that is that the standard vampire
illuminati uniform right there you said
it buddy
the immortal question is Jeremy if this
movie is good will you give it a good
review I certainly will I'm a fair
person that being said is not going to
be after seeing this I'm like I don't
know but think of it this way friends
it's almost over the last Twilight thing
we ever have to worry about it's almost
over probably one more trailer after
this yeah maybe two and then the movie
and then it's like any disaster natural
or otherwise this is going to blow past
us and it'll be awesome it's cool
then again they were talking reboot
earlier so who knows but as long as
there is a Twilight trailer or movie out
there I will be here to bring the videos
for you I can't really think of a
question since you guys seem to like
these Twilight videos that I do what's
your favorite video that I've done
sounds a little narcissistic for me to
ask but I certainly can't be like what's
your favorite Twilight character is it
the bed actor the girl with no
personality the pedophile or the girl
getting doodled so favorite video
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]